[Music]
ashlynn and Mila they're so cute they
walk in the morning with their pajamas
on and their dogs and their kids now the
young boy that never walks his how old
he did he walks he's too so oh no no he
never puts him down he's always on his
back
[Laughter]
getting caught up by his neighbor Ellen
today which is cool but apparently Ellen
has given Ashton a complex about his son
Dimitri not walking so now I take him
out of the thing like when once we get
to like purview of your house and I'm
like go ride the matrix
Ellen just calls it like she sees it of
course and expect to see a lot of that
with her Netflix stand-up special
relatable premieres December 18th now
this marks Ellen's return to the
stand-up stage for the first time in 15
years
Andy G of course has been with her from
the very beginning as we flash back to
when we first met Ellen give me the
rundown on how to say your name run guys
yeah it's DeGeneres why did you not go
say French and these young ladies
because I'm common folk I know need
putting on airs you know people gonna
see through that pick up the phone and
call up God oh it got a little cold god
bless you bless yourself
it's an incredible profession to get
paid to make people laugh the perfect
stranger opens adorning what is the
perfect stranger they have perfect hair
they're dressed perfectly that was 1984
Ellen was 26 and had just been named the
funniest person in America even back
then it was clear
Ellen was a smooth talker there's
millions of channels to choose from
myself keep it on Entertainment Tonight
constantly Entertainment Tonight is
what a show hi I'm Ellen DeGeneres and
I'm gonna take you backstage on my new
TV show which is called these friends of
mine fast forward about a decade Ellen
landed her own TV show but she told us
it was hard being a boss I don't think
you achieve anything by by bullying
people I'm going to a school right now
to try to learn how to to be like that
like how about this hey you'll do what I
say or else I am woman hear me roar in
numbers too big to ignore
next up came her own talk show and now
Ellen's worth an estimated eighty seven
point five million last night on Kimmel
she explained why she decided to return
to stand-up I used to joke all the time
when I was touring someday you'll all
come to me and then now they do so I
just stopped going out and then it had
been 15 years and I decided I I'm it
you could call this a full-circle moment
and the sixty year old is doing exactly
what she told us she wanted to do when
we first met Ellen I hope to be in
acting I want to do films I want to do
TV and still do the stand-up that's you
know I love doing this so I want to
continue doing this Ellen come on
through the ages
[Music]